tras lo que vamos es encontrar una
cantidad de naranjas es decir de
toneladas de naranjas que nos ayuden a
optimizar o más bien a encontrar la
ganancia máxima que nosotros podamos
obtener en el vídeo pasado estuvimos
construyendo la gráfica del ingreso
total que es la gráfica de la derecha en
la gráfica de la izquierda lo que
estamos analizando es qué pasa con el
precio de la naranja a comparación de la
cantidad de naranjas que yo voy a
producir recuerden que el precio estaba
dado en miles de pesos y la producción
estaba dada en toneladas ahora bien en
este vídeo lo que vamos a analizar es
qué pasa con el margen de ingresos el
margen de ingresos lo habíamos definido
como el cambio en el ingreso total entre
el cambio de la cantidad y habíamos
dicho que no era otra cosa más que la
pendiente de la recta tangente en un
punto de la curva del ingreso total y
habíamos comentado que este problema lo
resolvemos con cálculos sin embargo por
esta ocasión vamos a hacer una
aproximación por un método del g break o
así que manos a la obra para esto me voy
a fijar en cómo cambia mi ingreso total
al hacer yo un cambio muy pero muy
pequeño en mi cantidad entonces
una pequeña tabla en esta tabla voy a
poner la cantidad y cuando mi cantidad
vale cero pues mi ingreso total vale
cero también esto ya lo habíamos
calculado es el punto que tenemos en el
origen ahora bien qué pasa cuando mi
cantidad vale 0.001 es decir estoy
cambiando muy pero muy poco mi cantidad
cuando mi cantidad vale punto 0001 lo
podemos calcular tanto de esta forma
como en la gráfica de la izquierda sin
embargo voy a sacar mi calculadora y lo
voy a utilizar voy a sacarlo con la
fórmula que tengo del ingreso total es
decir menos q cuadrada más 6 entonces
vamos a entender la calculadora y yo
tengo menos quien menos punto 001
elevado al cuadrado elevado al cuadrado
ya esto hay que sumarle 6 veces 6 x
0.001
punto 0 0 1 y esto es igual a punto 0 0
5 99.00 599.000 599 y bueno ya cuando
esto yo puedo pensar en calcular el
margen de ingreso el margen de ingreso
lo que me pide es calcular la división
entre el cambio del ingreso total entre
el cambio de la cantidad y bueno ahora
sustituyendo el cambio de la cantidad de
20.001 y el cambio en el ingreso total
era 0.00 599 así que hay que hacer esta
división vamos a sacar la calculadora y
yo quiero dividir punto 0 0 59 999 entre
10.001 entonces el resultado entre punto
001 y esto nos da como resultado 5.999 y
más aún esta es la idea que hay detrás
del cálculo la idea de tomar un pequeño
cambio en cu
cerca de algún punto y ver qué es lo que
pasa con el cambio en el ingreso total
pero esto no acaba aquí fíjense que si
agarramos un punto más cercano al 0 por
ejemplo punto 0
001 entonces voy a obtener un punto más
cercano al 6 cuando yo calculé el margen
de ingresos por lo tanto yo puedo decir
que la pendiente de la recta tangente en
el punto cero es igual a 6 y esto
también lo podemos visualizar en la
gráfica de la izquierda cuando yo tengo
un punto muy cercano a 0 en la cantidad
el precio es casi 6 lo voy a dibujar
para que se vea mucho más claro para que
me entiendan mejor supongamos que yo
produzco una cantidad de naranjas cerca
a 0 toneladas es decir muy pocas
naranjas ah bueno lo que me dice mi
curva de que compara el precio con la
cantidad de naranjas es que yo puedo
vender esa cantidad de naranjas que yo
estoy produciendo en un precio de 6 mil
pesos por tonelada cercano a 6 mil pesos
por tonelada y aunque no tengan una
tonelada de naranjas las pocas naranjas
que yo tenga las puedo vender a ese
precio a eso se refiere el margen de
ingresos ahora vamos a calcular el
margen de ingresos en todos los demás
puntos vamos a fijarnos qué pasa cuando
yo produzco una tonelada de naranja
lo que voy a querer encontrar es la
pendiente de la recta tangente en el
punto 15 en la gráfica de la derecha y
para esto yo podría hacerlo de la misma
manera que lo calcula en 0 sin embargo
por un teorema que se utiliza bastante
en cálculo yo puedo aproximar está
pendiente de la pendiente que quiero
sacando la pendiente entre estos dos
puntos para eso necesito primero el
cambio en la cantidad el cual es 2 y el
cambio en el ingreso total el cual va de
0 a 8 por lo tanto es 8 entonces si yo
calculará la pendiente entre estos dos
puntos o el margen de ingreso entre
estos dos puntos sería 8 entre 2 es
decir 4 ya puedo con este 4 aproximar la
pendiente de la recta tangente en el
punto 15 o dicho de otra manera cuando
yo produzco una tonelada de naranjas mi
margen de ingresos es aproximadamente 4
y es una buena aproximación por lo tanto
voy a poner este punto también aquí para
ir creando la curva del margen de
ingresos ahora voy a ver qué pasa en el
punto 2,8
cuál va a ser la pendiente de la recta
tangente cuando yo produzco 2 toneladas
es decir lo que quiero es el margen de
ingresos cuando yo produzco 2 toneladas
y bueno de manera análoga al caso
anterior me voy a aplicar qué pasa con
los dos puntos que están al lado del
punto 25 y voy a calcular su pendiente
de igual manera el cambio entre esos dos
puntos es 2 en la cantidad mientras que
el cambio en el ingreso total va a ser
de 5 a 9 habíamos calculado que este
punto era 9 por lo tanto el cambio entre
5 y 9 es 4 y ya con esto tenemos una
buena aproximación del margen de
ingresos el margen de ingresos es el
cambio en el ingreso total que es 4
dividido entre el cambio en la cantidad
que es 2 por lo tanto cuando yo produzco
2 toneladas de naranjas mi margen de
ingresos es 2 o muy cercano a 2 entonces
lo voy a poner en esta tabla y voy a
hacer un punto más ahora me voy a fijar
qué pasa en el punto 39 en el punto 39
voy a calcular la pendiente de la recta
tangente o dicho de otra manera
voy a calcular el margen de ingresos sin
embargo a este punto se le conoce en
caso
como un punto máximo esta que es punto
cuya derivada es cero o dicho otra
manera la pendiente de la recta tangente
en ese punto es cero y se nota muy
claramente cuando yo hago el mismo
procedimiento que la vez pasada si me
fijo en los dos puntos que están al lado
de este punto el cambio en la cantidad
otra vez es 2 sin embargo el cambio en
el ingreso total es cero no hay un
cambio en el ingreso total y de hecho se
ve porque la pendiente de aquí pasa de
ser positiva
aquí tenemos pendientes positivas
pasamos por este punto cuya pendiente es
cero y después de este punto tenemos
pendientes negativas es decir cuando yo
produzco tres toneladas naranjas mi
margen de ingresos es cero y qué va a
pasar después de este punto pues después
de este punto el margen de ingresos es
negativo va decreciendo mi curva del
margen de ingresos por lo tanto después
de este punto va a ser negativo y esto
lo podemos ver también porque después de
un punto máximo las pendientes son
negativas y ahora sí si nosotros
dibujamos la curva del margen de
ingresos que de hecho es una recta nos
va a dar esta recta de amarillo que
tenemos aquí y además en este caso esta
recta cumple que tiene el doble
pendiente de la recta de la demanda la
recta de amarillo tiene el doble de
pendiente que la recta de azul que
teníamos originalmente la recta de
amarillo tiene pendiente menos 2
mientras que la recta da su última
pendiente menos 1 y eso qué quiere decir
a bueno que nosotros cuando aumentamos
una tonelada el precio decrece en 2
cuando aumentamos otra tonelada el
precio decrece en 2 cuando nosotros
aumentamos otra tonelada el precio
decrece en 2 bueno pero es hora de abrir
nuestra mente si quitamos todos estos
cálculos y toda esta álgebra qué
significa lo que acabamos de hacer esta
es la curva de demanda la cual nos dice
el precio que tiene una cierta cantidad
de producción o lo que es lo mismo para
cada una de nuestras cantidades posibles
de producción
cuál es el incremento del margen de
beneficio o mejor aún en cuánto podemos
vender una cierta producción ahora bien
mientras que la recta del margen de
ingresos que por cierto también es una
función que depende de la cantidad nos
dice lo siguiente si nosotros
disminuimos un poco la cantidad cuánto
va a decrecer nuestro ingreso y más aún
también lo que nos está diciendo es que
si disminuimos nuestra cantidad de
producción entonces el margen de
ingresos
mayor al margen de costos pero esto lo
veremos en el siguiente vídeo